how about this picture right here the
new cast of Dancing with the Stars you
got Marcia Marcia Marcia
Marilu Henner ryan lochte can't wait to
see if he can dance the stars gonna be
making their debut and just a minutes
and we have an exclusive sneak peek
where you gonna see tonight because only
we got to take our camera inside the
ballroom for their final preps Vanilla
Ice will jump out of a convertible and
dance to his most famous hit check out
the hook while my DJ drop off we saw a
sneak peek of Derek Hough lifting Marilu
Henner maureen McCormick and Artem took
a spin while Ryan Lochte looked pretty
friendly with cheryl burke draping his
arm around her shoulders don't need the
mission country singer jana kramer and
Gleb looked her ready to go
the couples arrived at 8 a.m. rehearsed
their opening number and kept going and
going up until tonight's premiere
we're gonna go rehearse she's gonna go
to bed and she's gonna wake up come back
here rehearse again dress rehearsal
Showtime
get the judges scores go gold
medal-winning gymnast Lauri Hernandez
and Val will dance to bunny Maki's
American Girl we are live from the stage
of Dancing with the Stars Lauri
Hernandez I heard you and your partner
have this amazing handshake do you mind
sharing this with us 6 7 here we go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen you saw it here
first
not so fast there Tara and Sasha I want
to one-up you I'm gonna go hey what's up
Tara I refer to this kind of like The
Hunger Games nobody wants to see each
other go but at the same time it's a
competition Tara and Sasha are doing the
jive and with this being dancing the
final touch the spray tan we're spraying
it today people